In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon for August 23rd, on which we commemorate the Holy
Martyr Lupus.
On the 23rd of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Lupus.
Lupus was a slave in the service of Saint Demetrius of Thessalonica. He was present at his master's
martyrdom and managed at that time to take his blood-stained tunic and royal ring, which were soaked
in the martyr's blood. After this, he worked many miracles and healings with these two trophies,
thus confirming the faith of the Christians. Because of this, the Emperor, who was still in
Thessalonica, had him arrested and tortured, he was condemned to death. But it is said that,
at the moment of his execution, the two soldiers charged with the task turned their swords on one
another and wounded each other. The martyr prayed that, as for himself, Christ would give him the
grace of baptism before his death. At that moment, a cloud stopped overhead and poured the necessary
water down on him. Thus, clothed in the new man, and in the power of the Holy Spirit,
Lupus endured the tortures with constancy before being beheaded. And he was thus
delivered from the bondage of this life to gain the kingdom of heaven.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.